in other news this afternoon the man  stabbed to death on a las vegas strip  pedestrian bridge saturday night has  been identified that is the suspect in  the case but the victim has been  identified as an off-duty police officer  from washington state the edmonds police  department says officer tyler steffens  leaves behind a wife and two children  edmunds is north of seattle 58 year old  freddy allen who you just saw there he  is accused of murdering stefans  detectives say stefans and another man  got into an argument over petting dogs  allen stepped in  allen refused to appear in court this  morning he faces an open murder charge  we're following that story we'll have a  lot more on that in later newscasts mean